pero el envío de armas a ucrania ha
desatado polémica en varios países no es
que desde algunos sectores están
señalando no que esto supone participar
en el conflicto y de alguna manera
pierde valor la vía diplomática de qué
opina usted
esa pregunta es difícil porque al fin
del día la decisión de dónde está la
línea directa y nadie sabe en realidad
pero mientras que no hay gan personal
soldados militares de las fuerzas de
otan en ucrania físicamente peleando se
puede argumentar que todavía no han
comenzado una guerra de otan contra la
rusia en este sentido encuentra usted
cierta contradicción quizás entre el
envío de armas y los llamados a la paz
bueno es que no están llamados nadie
está llamado a la paz aquí esto es una
guerra plena guerra internacional y este
el envío de armamentos esto es algo que
ha ocurrido por siglos no que un una
parte ayuda a otra parte pero en la
línea roja es cuando hay soldados
actuales o en la ucrania o sobre los
cielos de ucrania en
aviones de combate ahora por otra parte
quienes no coinciden con esta postura
que estamos describiendo advierten que
en manos de los atacados los armamentos
son defensivos y que para conseguir una
paz negociada que no implique el
sometimiento de ucrania las demandas
rusas es necesario fortalecer esa
defensa ucraniana ha avanzado cree usted
ucrania en este sentido en esta
contraofensiva
ha avanzado muchísimo bueno primero que
nada el objetivo principal de rusia era
capturar el país entero empezando con la
capital el cual obviamente los rusos no
pudieron lograr y en términos de la
parte ofensiva armamentos ascencio
ofensivos o defensiva
los iniciales todos los tengo en estos
hilos ya hablan si todo eso eran
esencialmente
armamentos defensivos ahora lo que están
dando en términos de la artillería
pesada y vehículos blindados eso se
puede utilizar ambos como defensa o
ofensiva ahora nos queda muy poco tiempo
pero no quiero dejar de hacerle esta
última pregunta no porque dada su
experiencia militar cómo evalúa usted la
estrategia ofensiva de rusia no sobre
todo en los últimos días que para muchos
ha habido una reprogramación una
reformulación quizás
eso fue cuestión de que no tenían otra
opción porque su plan inicial era
totalmente diferente como acabo de decir
anteriormente